hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american dystopian film
called the darkest minds
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
in the year 2043 in the united states
children and teenagers start to die
because of a terrible disease that only
afflicts children
this disease is contagious and spreads
very quickly
however this disease is only lethal to
children but not to adults
as a result of this virus ninety eight
percent of children and teens die
and only two percent of children survive
the disease and the children who survive
become abnormal
the disease triggers a special ability
in these children which makes them
dangerous
the government urges all parents to hand
over their surviving child to a camp for
healing and research
and at that time the president of
america president gray
claims that his son clancy has survived
the disease and is currently being
treated at the camp for healing and his
condition
is getting better in the camp doctors
and scientists classified children
and their disorders into five colors
first it is the greens
for children whose intelligence has
increased the second is blue for those
who have telekinetic abilities the third
group is gold
who have the power to manipulate
electricity the first three groups are
considered to be quite safe
and are only being treated in healing
camps the fourth group is the group that
is considered dangerous
which is the red color for those who can
control fire and the fifth group is
orange
the most dangerous group for those who
can manipulate the minds of other people
the red and orange groups are very rare
and the government considers them very
dangerous and orders them to be killed
immediately on site
the film takes us to a setting where a
little girl named ruby is celebrating
her birthday with her parents
they are worried because all the
children around are dead and only ruby
is still alive
at night ruby comes to her mother's room
to calm her down
but suddenly she has a strange vision
when she holds her mother's hand
in the morning her mother does not
recognize ruby as her child anymore
and her mother calls the government to
take ruby away to the healing camp
finally ruby is taken with the other
children to the healing camp
every child brought to the camp gets
examined by the doctor to determine what
abnormality they have
ruby is taken to the examination where
she is identified as being orange
the most dangerous group that can
control other people's minds
therefore the doctor immediately wants
to inject ruby with lethal injection
but ruby is able to control his mind and
convince him that she is green
the ones whose intelligence has improved
rapidly and is not considered dangerous
on the camp there are three groups green
blue
and gold but there are no red nor orange
because they are all killed immediately
on-site
ruby then lives her life in the camp as
a green six years have passed
ruby who is working in the camp is
scolded by the camp captain for making a
mistake
the captain feels that ruby is more
stupid than the other people there
and grows suspicious however ruby's
campaign tries to defend ruby and
insults the camp captain which
infuriates him and as a result
the captain takes her away for
punishment the children are treated
really badly in the camp later at the
camp
frequency tests are often held in short
this frequency test is a test that uses
a very loud sound whose frequency can
only be heard by the children
during this frequency test ruby faints
and she is taken to a doctor called dr
kate for further examination from the
examination
the officer finds out that ruby is an
orange dr kate secretly writes a note to
ruby that they have found out ruby is an
orange and will kill her immediately
and dr kate tells ruby to meet her in
the boiler room
in a panic ruby then directly goes to
the boiler room and in there dr kate is
waiting for her
by that time the alarm has been sounded
for an intrusion
and all officers are ordered to look for
ruby with dr kate's help
ruby manages to leave using dr kate's
car but at the checkpoint
ruby is almost caught but ruby uses her
power to control the officer's mind to
let them escape
finally after six years ruby manages to
get out of the camp
in the car kate gives ruby a panic
button that can be activated as a
tracker if she is in danger
kate explains that she is part of the
children's league whose mission is to
save children from the camp and fight
the government
kate takes her to a gas station to meet
her boyfriend rob who is also on a child
rescue mission
but when ruby almost falls and holds
rob's hand she has a vision of rob
who seems to like abusing children ruby
becomes suspicious of their motives
when ruby changes her clothes at a shop
she suddenly sees a small girl who can
manipulate electricity
the girl runs away when she sees ruby
and ruby chases after her
the girl then gets into a van and ruby
follows her to hide from dr kate
the little girl is called sue and she is
a mute and always wears gloves due to
her ability
sue is accompanied by two friends called
liam and charles
liam is a blue with telekinesis ability
while the intelligent charles is a green
they agree to go with ruby and help her
escape from kate on the way
there is a woman who tries to chase them
her name is lady jane
lady jane is a child hunter who works
for money while in pursuit
kate also tries to pursue them however
liam uses his telekinesis power to
harass them by scattering the leaves
cracking the road and even knocking down
the trees
as a result they manage to escape they
also begin to get to know each other
better but ruby does not reveal her
identity as orange and lies that she is
a green
liam explains that they are on their way
down the east river to a group of
children led by a mysterious person
nicknamed the slipkid
they don't know the identity of the
slipkid but it looks like he's an orange
who can control people's minds
he also explains that the children's
league led by dr kate is not a good
place to stay he used to be in the
children's league where they trained
children to use their abilities to fight
against the government
liam didn't like the idea of becoming a
soldier and so he eventually left the
league
meanwhile ruby and the others spend the
night at an end
ruby remembers the time with her parents
it is revealed that she couldn't really
control her ability
and because of that she accidentally
erased her parents memories of her when
she was a kid
while sleeping ruby accidentally touches
sue's hand and then gets a memory that
sue used to be in a government camp
but eventually she and hundreds of other
children rebelled and fled and the
rebellion was led by liam
because of the trauma during her life at
the camp sue became mute
in the morning they go to a long
abandoned mall to shop and pick up some
supplies
they really enjoy their moment together
since they never have a normal childhood
but suddenly their bodies are lifted and
controlled by a group of people
luckily sue uses her electric power to
stop it
it turns out that they are also a group
of children who have telekinesis
abilities
at night they talk about the children's
association in the east river in its
very secret nature
they know where east river is but they
can't tell ruby and her friends the
exact location because it's a secret
they cannot tell
however ruby uses her telepathy secretly
to make one of them unconsciously gives
a clue about the location
which is the letter edo later that night
the genius charles tries to figure out
what edio is
but he finds nothing however after
speaking with ruby about her father
being a cop
charles starts to realize that edo might
be a radio frequency
he concludes that he represents five d
represents four
and o represents zero and he uses the
number 540 for the radio frequency
finally they receive a message from the
frequency and finds that the location is
at lake prince virginia
the next day on the road they are
ambushed by lady jane
the child hunter and she uses the sound
frequency of her rifle to incapacitate
the children
luckily ruby uses her power to control
lady jane's mind
and gives jane a deserving punishment
liam and the others are shocked that all
this time ruby is orange
it turns out that ruby has lied to them
all this time because she isn't proud of
her abilities
some time later ruby confides with liam
about her past
and they start to fall in love with each
other finally
they continue their journey and arrive
at lake prince virginia
there they meet other children like
themselves they are so amazed because
they haven't seen that many children in
a very long time
they also meet the slip kid and it turns
out that all this time
he is the son of the president clency
gray clancy is an orange
just like ruby at night they have a
party
liam and ruby dance together
romantically in the morning
they're all given an assignment and ruby
is assigned to help clancy
clancy tells ruby that he is one of the
first people to survive the terrible
disease
and the government used him to
experiment to create a cure
but the doctor failed and his father the
president
lied to the public that they had found
the cure clancy eventually escaped and
formed a children's association where
all the children can live safely
clancy then teaches ruby how to control
her power and control other people's
minds without touching their hands and
ruby finally succeeds
in return ruby teaches him how to erase
people's memories
however during this process clancy
controls her mind and tries to kiss her
ruby is distraught and she hits him and
leaves ruby and her friends finally
decide to leave the place
but while on the run they are ambushed
by troops from the camp
liam tries to fight back but suddenly he
becomes unconscious
it turns out that clancy has made him
unconscious it is revealed that all this
time
clancy has been the mastermind behind it
all clancy has contacted the camp
captain to arrest all the children
clancy has been manipulating his father
the president and taking control of the
government using his power
his main goal is to create his army of
children with superpowers so that he
would never get abused by anyone
ruby then uses her power to make the
camp captain commit suicide
and sue controls the electricity to
create a trick to escape
suddenly armed forces arrive with
helicopters to arrest all the children
the troops brought the children in the
red group who can control fire
it turns out that they are secretly
weaponized by the government and they
set the camp on fire
the battle finally ensues the red army
tries to burn liam and his friends but
liam uses his power to retaliate
but suddenly clancy comes in the middle
of the battle and manipulates the minds
of all the children there
liam and the others are forced to leave
the location and leave ruby there
because only ruby has the power to face
clancy ruby uses her ability to create
her army
however clancy shows his brutal nature
and controls their mind to kill
themselves by shooting each other
clancy then tries to use his new memory
erasing powers to turn ruby to his side
and forget her friends but ruby uses her
power to control the pilot's mind
and a helicopter crashes and explodes
ruby manages to escape the explosion
with the help of charles
but unfortunately charles gets burned
and he is severely injured
leaving ruby no choice but to use her
panic button to call the children's
league for help
the next morning the league squad comes
to pick them all up
charles is immediately taken to the
hospital for treatment while tzu is
adopted by a good family
but liam is arrested by the lead because
he has betrayed the league before
the league considers liam knows too much
about the league to be left free
ruby meets kate and bargains to release
liam by promising to be a soldier in the
league
and fight against the government
alongside them however
kate is sure that liam will never leave
without ruby and he won't let ruby join
the league
finally ruby meets liam liam explains
that he wants the two of them to stay
together and discuss plans for both of
them in the future
but ruby is forced to erase herself from
liam's memory so that liam can be
released and so that she can join and
fight with the children's league
all memories of ruby from their first
meeting in the van chatting together and
dancing together
are all gone from his memory suddenly
liam doesn't remember anything about
ruby
and liam leaves ruby then cries as she
sees liam leave
at the end of the story ruby joins and
trains with the children's league
but there is more the struggle of ruby
and her friends is far from over
because it turns out that clancy is
still alive and a fierce battle between
the two sides will be inevitable
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching